no ceasefire and no backing down despite
American please if anything the
Fighting's seem to pick up pace but the
growing condemnation has pardoned
Turkish resolve the country's vice
president delivered a tough message at
the presidential palace no amount of
arms embargoes or sanctions are going to
deter them sanctions of course we have
considered about section sanctions we do
consider about sanctions but we none of
those sanctions can be a threat can be a
more threat than the threat comes from
the other side of the border terror
strikes so as Turkey we are decisive
very determined to clear up the area
from the terrorists no matter what
happens no matter who says what and
Turkey insists its operation is a fight
against terrorism no matter that the
people they're aiming their guns at were
only a few days ago their allies allies
turkey says America and Britain chose
the wrong partners there's a state
fighting against a terrorist
organization it fighting against
terrorism
and you expect us to sit and talk with
it with terrorists they were former
allies of the Americans and the British
that's disappearing if US and British or
any other country around the world ally
with the terrorists so we hope that they
don't have a misunderstanding of who
they are otherwise we don't want to
consider that any country well i with us
are the allies or terrorists in other
words you can't be allies with us both
on the battlefield in the key tale of
manbij it was Russian flags flying
President Putin seems to be filling the
vacuum left by the Americans with turkey
ready to take on the Syrian regime to
snatch manbij we have been talking with
Russia as well our ministers and our
institutions are in constant talk with
all the parts again we hope that that's
not going to be the issue but we are
determined to take the control of the
area in the theater of war the injuries
and deaths are mounting and the UK's
decision to join the EU arms embargo on
Turkey will make little difference
turkey is pressing ahead
we are extremely careful extremely
careful for civilian casualties for kids
woman and elderly
extremely curve but the Fighting's
displaced hundreds of thousands and
turkey insists the refugees are Europe's
problem too so European countries have
to stand up and have to take the
responsibility so if they want to go to
Europe we can prevent for for it for a
certain time what we have done so far
what we cannot do it again forever so
this is another threat in it this is a
reality one week on the region's
landscape has changed dramatically the
only constant is the misery for the
civilians Alex Crawford Sky News Turkey